[Musique]
alors il y a l'année dernière dans mon
entreprise on a fait un bilan carbone
j'ai fait faire un bilan carbone voir
vous pouvez s'améliorer et puis j'en ai
profité il y a quelques mois pour faire
mon bilan carbone personnel je suis allé
sur un site internet
recommandé par l'ADEME j'ai répondu à
quelques questions ça m'a pris 10 15
minutes et puis j'ai vu les résultats
bon c'était pas mal mais améliorable
alors il y avait quelques pistes
d'amélioration certaines compliquées
d'autres beaucoup plus simple et la plus
simple d'entre elles c'était de réduire
la température du chauffage de ma maison
réduire d'un degré ça fait quelques
économies et c'est pas si difficile à
vivre et donc j'ai acheté un pull
voilà
pour pouvoir supporter la baisse de
température
donc je suis sorti bien j'étais un homme
bien sérieux je contribué à l'effort
collectif
ça m'a donné bonne conscience puis après
j'ai regardé mon pull je me suis dit
mais lui est-ce qu'il est éthique
quel est l'impact de ce pull sur
l'environnement dans quelles conditions
il a été produit d'où il vient alors
j'ai regardé les étiquettes
made in France dans ce cas là c'est pas
mal
j'imagine qu'il y a une grosse partie
qui est faite en France j'ai regardé les
autres étiquettes
trouver
un label très bien c'est du 100% l'air
super
alors j'ai quelques informations
lesquelles conclusions je peux en tirer
je peux me dire c'est de la laine c'est
naturel c'est bien comme le coton c'est
naturel c'est super puis le polyester
c'est synthétique c'est mal c'est fait
en France c'est bien et puis si c'était
fait en Asie c'est loin c'est mal parce
que conditions de production sont
peut-être pas toujours respectueuse des
hommes et de l'environnement
finalement je me base un peu sur des
présupposés parce que
quand on regarde dans le détail le coton
bah oui c'est naturel mais en même temps
ça nécessite des dizaines de milliers de
litres d'eau à la production de chaque
kilo de coton la laine ça vient des
moutons et les moutons ça émet du
méthane
le polyester c'est synthétique mais ça
peut être aussi durable ça peut être
aussi clair et puis la Chine c'est loin
mais le transport en bateau de la Chine
ça met un peu de CO2 mais pas beaucoup
en fait on pue comme ça c'est 200 g de
CO2 et puis les conditions de production
de les usines chinoises oui ça peut être
terrible puis aussi des usines dans
lequel des conditions sont bonnes
finalement j'en sais rien je sais pas je
sais pas concrètement quel est l'impact
de ce pull
j'ai quand même fait le calcul
rapidement entre baisser d'un degré et
acheter un pull vaut mieux quand même
acheter un pull surtout que j'en ai
quand même besoin quand je sors donc
c'est pas un achat supplémentaire
et donc finalement les questions
auxquelles j'aurais bien aimé avoir les
réponses c'est qui a travaillé sur mon
pull d'où il vient quels sont les
impacts sur l'eau sur l'air sur les gaz
à effet de serre est-ce que ça respecte
les le bien-être animal par exemple
et ces questions là j'aimerais bien la
poser à la marque en question
alors la marque elle
elle a pas toutes les réponses non plus
elle a pas toute la réponse parce que
elle elle fabrique en général mais c'est
pas elle qui fait le fil
donc elle va se retourner vers le fil à
terre
le filateur il a une partie des réponses
bien sûr il y a encore il calcule pas
tout
on n'est pas nécessairement sa
consommation d'électricité l'impact sur
les eaux quand il lave le fil il va se
retourner vers l'usine de péage aussi
celle qui fournit les ballots de laine
qui est pareil à une partie des réponses
etc jusqu'à l'éleveur l'éleveur qui se
retrouve en qui est en Argentine par
exemple qui lui est
connaissait bête c'est les élever mais
il connaît pas les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de ses bêtes qui peuvent
dépendre aussi de l'alimentation
finalement la marque à laquelle vous
adressez n'a pas nécessairement la
réponse parce que c'est compliqué c'est
pas un faisable mais c'est compliqué et
puis de l'autre côté d'un côté il y a le
consommateur vous et de l'autre côté il
y a la réglementation parce que la
réglementation dans ce secteur là comme
on sait être de plus en plus exigeante
la réglementation française puis ensuite
souvent reprise en Europe et elle
redescend en France après
sur l'étiquetages environnementales sur
les conditions de production
tout ça est bien compliqué
et il y a plusieurs réponses à ça
comment mesurer l'impact environnemental
et social et animal d'un pull
une réponse c'est la traçabilité
blockchain c'est le surjet sur lequel je
travaille
traçabilité et blockchain je vais
expliquer le premier terme alors la
blockchain c'est une technologie
informatique dont j'imagine beaucoup
d'entre vous ont entendu parler
et peut-être une partie d'entre vous ont
compris à quoi ça servait
il y a quelques années j'avais rencontré
un directeur informatique d'une grande
entreprise pour le présenter mon
activité il me dit oui la blockchain je
vois très bien de quoi il s'agit mais
faites comme si je ne connaissais rien
donc même si vous connaissez quelque
chose je vais faire comme si vous
connaissez rien aussi alors je vais
faire un parallèle
imaginons que vous prêtez de l'argent à
un ami et que vous avez envie d'écrire
cette information
de manière sécurisée de telle sorte que
personne puisse la modifier vous avez
envie d'écrire le montant la date le nom
de votre nom et celui de votre ami puis
vos signatures communes
une méthode que je vous propose qui est
pas nécessairement la plus pratique et
qui fonctionne vous allez graver ces
informations sur une plaque de marbre
comme les Romains à l'époque on voulait
graver vous signez et puis ensuite la
plaque vous allez la donner à une
personne
et puis pour maximiser la sécurité vous
allez graver une deuxième plaque de
marbre avec pareil même information le
montant votre nom celui de votre ami et
vos signatures vous gravez cette plaque
vous allez la donner une deuxième
personne et ainsi de suite au bout d'un
moment vous avez donné vos plaques à
différentes personnes des dizaines des
centaines qui sont indépendantes les
unes des autres ça sécurise
l'information
par exemple si vous voulez lire
l'information vous demandez la plaque à
quelqu'un et puis une deuxième personne
et si c'est la même
vérifier avec une troisième si c'est
trois fois la même il y a bonne chance
que ce soit l'information d'origine
et puis si deuxième personne veut aussi
enregistrer le prêt d'argent un ami elle
va faire sa propre plaque elle va
envoyer la première personne
qui va accrocher à la première plaque
avec un cadenas sécurisé
elle va faire une deuxième plaque avec
la même information qu'elle va donner
une deuxième personne etc il y a à la
fin vous avez 200 personnes qui ont
chacune de plaques et ainsi de suite et
au fur et à mesure vous allez accrocher
des plaques au fur et à mesure des
informations que vous allez devoir
rajouter
ça marche bien parce que si jamais
quelqu'un veut modifier une information
il va devoir aller voir toutes les
personnes qui possèdent des plaques
décrocher à leur insu la plaque
d'origine mettre sa propre plaque et la
raccrocher
la blockchain c'est ça mais en digital
parce que les plaques de marbre c'est
pas très pratique c'est un peu lourd
donc la blockchain c'est je prends une
information je l'enregistre sur un
serveur un ordinateur je l'accroche aux
informations précédentes et je duplique
tout ça sur tous les serveurs qui sont
connectés à la même blockchain ça
fonctionne très bien c'était inventé en
2008 pour une première application qui
était le Bitcoin
il y a eu beaucoup de critiques sur la
blockchain à juste titre c'est que cette
première application consomme énormément
d'électricité et donc dans certains pays
ça veut dire énormément de charbon mais
les dernières versions de la technologie
qui se sont améliorées comme toutes
technologie ça s'améliore consomme très
très peu d'électricité
ça c'est pour la blockchain j'enregistre
de la formation et je suis sûr qu'elle
n'est pas modifiable derrière donc je
participe à la confiance de
l'information
le deuxième élément c'est la traçabilité
donc la traçabilité c'est
collecter de l'information sur une
filière une filière je voulais décris
tout à l'heure c'est
les éleveurs de moutons en Argentine en
Nouvelle-Zélande aux États-Unis par
exemple
une filière c'est ensuite l'usine de
péage
la filature le tricotage et le montage
jusqu'au pull final vous voyez derrière
ça peut être aussi dans l'alimentaire
je vais pousser du blé j'en fais de la
farine j'en fais du pain et je le vends
une filière c'est tous les gens qui
courent à produire un produit final donc
la traçabilité c'est de collecter de
l'information auprès de ces gens-là sur
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait aujourd'hui
combien de temps ils ont produit combien
de kilos de laine ils ont tondu sur les
montants et puis aussi collecter
l'information sur des gens qui gravitent
autour qui sont par exemple les
organismes d'audit éthiques sur les
conditions de travail sur le respect de
l'animal les laboratoires qui font des
analyses qualité
tout ce qui est conformité aussi donc à
la fin
grâce à cette information que vous
collectez sur le produit final que ce
soit une baguette de pain ou un pull
comme ici vous avez tout un tas
d'informations qui vous éclairent sur ce
pull
ça fait beaucoup d'informations et on
peut se dire ouais mais c'est quand même
compliqué parce que entre l'éleveur
argentin dans sa pampa et puis l'usine
de filature qui est en Allemagne par
exemple ou en Europe de l'Est et puis la
fabrication en France ça fait beaucoup
de gens
oui c'est compliqué mais de moins en
moins parce que d'une part tous ces gens
là commencent à être équipés en
informatique
on trace des filières internationales en
Asie en Afrique du Sud
en Amérique du Sud et de plus en plus de
personnes même les éleveurs de moutons
dans la pampa Argentine ou uruguayen
sont équipés au moins avec un téléphone
portable donc on peut collecter de
l'information auprès de parce que sur
leur système ils enregistrent ce qu'il
faut
et puis deuxième élément après la
digitalisation
progressive de tous ces acteurs
c'est que les filières en tout cas dans
secteur mais même dans tous les secteurs
que ce soit l'automobile
la mode ou l'agroalimentaire ont
tendance à se stabiliser
stabiliser ça veut dire que jusqu'à
récemment et ça perdure encore vous êtes
filateur et vous allez chercher le la
laine la moins chère peu importe les
conditions de production donc une année
vous allez vous fournir auprès de
quelqu'un l'année suivante auprès de
quelqu'un d'autre on s'est super pour
avoir des prix bas mais ensuite pour
s'assurer d'avoir des produits en
condition éthiques et responsables c'est
plus difficile donc la tendance globale
ça va venir petit à petit c'est pas vrai
partout c'est de stabiliser les filières
c'est à dire que chaque entité fait des
contrats cadres avec ses fournisseurs ça
permet de rassurer le fournisseur et
aussi de exiger de sa part qui respecte
un syndrome de règles comme je vous l'ai
dit le respect de l'environnement des
travailleurs et des animaux
donc on collecte toutes ces informations
et ensuite elle est restituée elle peut
être restituée par exemple ici au
responsables approvisionnement de la
marque il sait exactement ce qui se
passe sur sa filière s'il aura assez de
laine s'il y a eu assez de la du côté
des moutons pour produire les pulls
aussi aux responsables qu'on appelle RSE
ça veut dire responsabilité sociale des
entreprises qui lui va pouvoir si toute
la chaîne en amont respecte son cahier
des charges et
et puis le consommateur
donc le consommateur sur son produit
imaginons et ça on le fait on met un QR
code il se scanne et puis il a tout
information sur son produit
et bien on va lui dire ta laine elle
vient de du ruguay sur ce pull là sur ce
fameux pull elle était filée en
Allemagne
le pull a été fabriqué en France dans
l'ouest de la France par exemple
et puis l'émission de gaz effet de serre
total de ce produit là c'est pour 20 kg
de gaz à effet de serre principalement
du méthane
on parle en équivalent CO2 donc c'est
pas 20 kg de CO2 c'est beaucoup moins
aussi on va lui parler d'écoute toxicité
on va lui parler aussi d'autres
officialisation des eaux c'est des
termes un peu techniques
qui posent une question c'est on peut
fournir au consommateur plein plein
d'informations très très précise et
après est-ce que la consommateur va
pouvoir les comprendre
quand on parle des côtes toxicité c'est
un peu technique comme terme
et c'est là où
c'est un peu les limites de la
transparence c'est pas les limites en
disant on va pas être transparence et
surtout il faut communiquer auprès des
consommateurs c'est important et aussi
faut que les consommateurs aillent se
renseigner sur ce qui se passe ce que
veut dire chacune des informations qu'il
a sous les yeux et c'est là le rôle des
experts des journalistes des gens qui
vont analyser les résultats pour en
faire une information un peu digérable
finalement votre rôle en tant que
consommateur c'est d'aller voir
l'information puis aller voir des gens
des sources fiables qui commandent cette
information
il y a une deuxième limite aussi c'est
le c'est le secret des affaires c'est à
dire qu'il y a des choses qui peuvent
être confidentielles les informations
sensibles pas que les marques qui ont
envie de cacher des choses aux
consommateur mais par exemple savoir
quelle est la ferme exactement en
Uruguay le nom de la ferme le nom de
l'éleveur qui a fourni la laine le
consommateur peut être n'a pas besoin il
a besoin de savoir dans quelle région
c'était parce que le nom de l'éleveur le
nom de qui a produit la laine c'est une
information sensible
le filateur il a besoin de protéger ses
sources d'approvisionnement aussi
donc finalement
ce qu'on a vu c'est que
vous avez des marques
sur lesquelles il y a de plus en plus de
pression des consommateurs et de la
réglementation et même les marques
elles-mêmes elles ont besoin de protéger
le capital de marque peut être embarqué
dans un scandale le pouvoir pour pouvoir
progresser il faut collecter de
l'information pour savoir concrètement
ce qui se passe et là où elles peuvent
agir que la traçabilité blockchain c'est
une solution qui répond à ce besoin de
transparence en information et enfin le
bout de la chaîne le rôle du
consommateur c'est de s'informer et
pouvoir faire des choix éclairés
et comme le thème de cette addict c'est
ouvrir la voie si j'ai bien compris je
vous propose quelques pistes quelques
pistes pour vous vous les prenez si vous
le voulez bien sûr
un faites votre bilan carbone ça va vous
prendre un quart d'heure ça vous éclaire
sur quel est votre impact et puis voir
là où vous pouvez progresser
de renseignez-vous aussi tout ce qui est
impact environnemental tout ce qui est
émission de gaz effet de serre comme je
l'ai dit le trophisation des eaux ça
paraît très complexe mais finalement ça
n'est pas de temps
l'éco-toxicité aussi ces termes-là
est-ce que faire venir un produit de le
bout de la terre c'est c'est plus écolo
ou moins écolo que de le faire le même
en France c'est pas sûr un élevage
extensif en Nouvelle-Zélande c'est
peut-être plus vertueux qu'un élevage
intensif en France
renseignez-vous et puis pour ceux qui
vont aller en entreprise d'ici quelques
années ou pour ceux qui sont déjà aussi
posé des questions sur votre activité
sur une petite parenthèse là c'est que
on entend souvent que les jeunes sont
sensibles à l'environnement et quelque
part j'ai l'impression que les gens qui
ont 45 ans ils se disent bon on a merdé
on va compter sur les jeunes pour
réparer ce qu'on a fait je pense que si
le message que je passe il vaut aussi
pour les jeunes et pour les moins jeunes
pour se rendre compte quelle erreur
impact et comment ils peuvent agir on
peut quand même agir et changer ses
habitudes à 40 ou 50 ans
troisième point renseignez-vous sur ce
que vous achetez alors un pull bon il y
a pas un gros impact quand même mais sur
le logement votre isolation vos moyens
de transport la voiture que vous allez
acheter ou que vous allez pas acheter et
vous allez acheter un vélo électrique à
la place renseignez-vous sur l'impact de
ce que vous achetez et puis si vous avez
pas l'info laissez tomber acheter autre
chose
et puis dernier point c'est que ce pull
là
je vous ai dit l'impact en équivalent en
CO2 c'est peut-être 20 kg
10 en fonction des conditions d'élevage
et si ce bulle je le jette au bout de
lavage c'est-à-dire au bout de trois
mois deux mois ça pas du tout le même
impact que s'il dure 10 donc ce qui
compte aussi c'est la durabilité des
produits acheter des produits fiables et
puis des produits qu'on peut réparer
ça qui est important
merci
[Applaudissements]